how to build a successful software
company so I got a great question from
one of my youtube viewers love you guys
Ahmed who wrote in to say hello Evan I'm
a student from computer science and I
love computers and IT I wish to do
something in this field in the video you
mentioned the software company could you
please tell me something about it or how
to do business as a software developer
thanks a lot Evan I mean this is a great
question and a lot of people want to get
in the software and to build a
successful software company you need two
things you need to have the skill set
needed to build a company and you need
to have a purpose that everybody is
rallying around so what you have here
now is you have some skills right your
your programming your software developer
you have all the IT skills so you have
some of the skills that you need to
build a business what you need to do to
be successful is to have all of the
other skills around you right you need
the leadership you need the sales you
need the marketing you need the customer
support skills you need to strategy all
the things needed to build a business
and you may be weak on those you may
have an interest in learning those
things and getting better at them or you
may think you know what I have no
interest in that stuff I just want to
cut code and build awesome software so
the bill that successful company you
need that complete rounded skill set and
it may involve bringing on other people
who have those skills to complement you
the second thing you need is the purpose
like what are you here to do what is
your company all about what kind of
amazing software do you want to build
and having a clear purpose will make it
easier for you to stay motivated but
also easy to attract like-minded people
with complementary skill sets right so
if you're going to be the developer and
you need somebody to do the sales and
marketing why am i going to come and
work with you it's because you're
standing for something important right
you're the purpose of your business is
important you're going to be adding a
lot of value to people's lives you're
going to be changing the world somehow
so understanding that clear purpose
makes it easy to attract the people
around you who have complementary skill
sets and believe in the same thing ok so
again you need to have
the right skill sets on your team and
you need to have the core purpose
everybody can rally around so my
background the first company I had the
first real company that took off and did
well was was a biotechnology software
company and I joined I wasn't one of the
founders I joined as an owner later on
and the two founders had created a great
piece of software and what I loved about
it was that it was doing good it was
research software to help scientists and
the software is being used to try to
find cures for cancer and AIDS and
diabetes important stuff right I wanted
to feel when I was university I want the
feel I would still do but I wanted to
feel like I was doing something
important right might the work I was
doing was meaningful and I was having a
positive impact on the world somehow
that's what I wanted to feel and so I
love that about this company I had zero
background in computers zero background
in software I sucked at science it was
my worst subject in in high school and I
dropped it as soon as I could
so now to be you know an owner in a
scientific software companies is almost
a joke and I'm sure my science teachers
would have laughed at me and said
there's no way that's even possible and
that wasn't the skillset I was bringing
right I was bringing the business
development the PR the marketing the
strategy that stuff and I believed in
what the company stood for so combined
we were with a build a successful
company we were able to get NASA Johnson
Johnson big companies on board in over
30 countries and blow this company up in
a short amount of time and then get
acquired that's what makes a difference
it's not just having one skill it's
having that skill surrounding yourself
with complimentary people and standing
for something important having a key
purpose of driving all of you forward
that's how you build a successful
software company belief for those who
are watching like the video you can
support me by clicking on the link in
the description leave a comment let me
know you think let me know if you have
any questions and if you want to see
more videos like this you can click on
my face to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon